yo what's up guys prestige here oh you
see i have new armor
prestige here with the fourth
fourth episode i'm gonna say what it's
not that apologies
of my divine survival rpg or
divine road divine experience something
along divine
and i'm using if you're new to this i'm
using divine rpg mod
and i'm just playing minecraft with it
so let's get into it
so yeah you guys can see i have new
armor and this is
elite reel on my i got it by er using
the same thing as
real amite except crafting uh blocks of
it
and then putting it in the same
formation to get better armor it's
infinite
more damage reduction and fall i don't
take any fall damage
now we got a lot of stuff that we're
going to be doing i started a cact like
i did a lot of stuff off screen which i
think
there's going to be more of a series
where there's a lot of stuff off screen
that i do
uh you see my cow farm's a lot better i
got a full enchanting room
um cactus farm over there so
it made this bigger there's a lot it's
not going to be uh
as rigorous as ever i show you guys
everything it's kind of just going to be
i'll show you guys when it happens i'll
show you guys the cool stuff
so this episode we have a lot of stuff
they want to get done all right first
we we i did get some a lot of levels and
enchant some books and i got
some but i got looting on this as well
to get better stuff because to get these
aquatic ingots
now we're gonna make the let's get a
stick there
and boom boom boom boom boom the aquaton
which is yeah since if we take this
and this out then we have the aquatic
trident which is
15 mega damage 7000 uses then we have
the aquaton which is 18
10 000 uses for again it's not infinite
but
this is where our good damage sword is
going to be
then we're going to get in here since
well we could actually enchant it
but i'm not going to since i got to use
it for this
so aquaton and
fire aspects i also do want to get
sharpness and fire aspect
that this is going to cost 10 and if i
change it is 17
no um
okay there we go now that's a beast now
we're also
all right so i got a bunch more rupees
by killing the eyes and i still have
even i've nine more
i made the set of rupee tools because i
wanna
do this it is the
rupee chic axe infinite uses uh
16 let's okay yeah it make sure wow that
is fast
and nothing is going to be that fast
oh it's not like crazy but you see it
looks like a pick
but it's i was just using it as a shovel
but but don't don't worry still got its
pick qualities
pretty fast pick at that then we go over
here
and oh wow it breaks trees
oh and it can even
till ground so this is an all-in-one
tool
and definitely awesome and i'm going to
hope this ooh very damage anvil
hopefully get efficiency 4 on it
and let's go check it out
there we go we're not op at all no
and that is infinite uses so
okay yep yep we're good we're for where
forever we are set
forever bro i actually i do want to
check something since the highest class
of tool
without any uh oh no no
okay okay it's not like crazy fast in
this but the highest set of tool has
like the efficiency of like 55 compared
to this 16
and you can literally tunnel sprint you
can do a full on sprint and it will
break to block i'll make a two block
tunnel
with just insanity so um i really don't
need this pic you can see there's my
other wheel of my armor
so i'm gonna throw this uh this in here
this is the gear
so this is like ever say i die this is
back up stuff that i'm gonna use
we got a power one bow which isn't too
good but and then we got
a blood gem sword i'm going to keep that
since when i need a spam click people
uh like bosses i'll probably want to use
that a little bit
and this now yeah i do want to get a
book with
sharpness let's see if we can pick one
of those do we have any books
uh smite one smite three um
we have leather and i think we have
paper
so can i put this in
no it's already enchanted so i can't do
that but i can if i get a sharpness
enchantment
i can uh
i can well you can say
uh yeah sorry this one computer
sharpness one it's better than nothing
ten i dang it oh i'm only level one okay
well let's go kill them some mobs
and yeah so also um
because my armor has infinite uses i
cannot
upgrade it normally conventionally so
i'm going to need to get books
i can just one hit these guys and the
fire aspect will kill them
nope you land in the water so yeah i do
only have
now i have 996 uses which still a lot of
uses but
okay so what else did i want to do this
episode so you see i have these things
these are for cyclopses
so i've been really just killing mobs
for a while
you can see tons of steak
and got a bigger farm i was thinking i
want to go back to the nether
except the stupid i killed a zombie
pigman one time
and now they're pissed at me for like
ever
so sucks yeah
i should kill some cows i still need
cow's leather for uh
for books so i'm gonna kill a few
and one two three four five
five should be good since it does
have looting too so we'll we'll see how
much we get
make sure we get all the stuff i think
we
got any any loot
six not bad that is six six books
and we can also i got tons of torches
because there's this thing called the
eye
i'm not sure i've shown you guys the
gameplay of it
but it drops
like a half a stack to a stack of
torches and when i'm using looting
it drops a lot more torches
all right well we got over a stack of
that stuff did you get locked into us
okay look at this
so yeah this will just be for uh mobs
that like we can't really trap and we
still need to fights
it'll just make those fights go by
faster
yeah i guess we can go into the
netherlands
hello one jko awesome
awesome we can go another just to see if
uh no oh i don't want to go here no no
no go back go back go back i don't want
to be here
no i do not want to be here go back
go back please thank you
oh gosh i that i hate that dimension so
much
i do have better armor now but isolate
it
i was trying to eat some steak
so you can see i blocked it out
are you so pissed at me
i have a feeling this will pissed at me
you still pissed ow yup still pissed
bye bye now
so yeah i'm really happy that we got the
[ __ ] especially with that uh
efficiency for and since the infinite
uses i never have to worry about it
breaking
that's good that is good good
okay let's see what do i want to do
i don't know i have no fail
open sesame
oh wrong chest
throw y'all in there actually i can make
oh i have another piece of leather
make some books
i probably shouldn't be standing on that
come on
bum
full stack
all right now we got ourselves some
books
throw them there we don't really want
some smite since it's not really like
helpful
only works against skeletons and zombies
let's see uh let's keep you in there for
now what to do what to do
what should we do let's see we can
start working on
yeah i want to go to nether to get like
some of the resources
i think if i get one of you and one of
you i think that crafts
a shadow bar
yeah and i get another right chunk
and then we throw you here together we
get a hell's turning
since we need hell starting get to make
one of them boss spawners
bosh spawner peoples
that's good except i don't know how to
make it i think i need
three of these one of you and what else
is it just that let's see i know it's
like that except i thought it was like
that
and there's something in the middle
clock maybe let's make a clock
i have gotten a good amount of gold
hopefully it is a clock or else i'm just
going to waste it on a clock
come on buddy yeah mysterious clock
all right that is how we summon the
uh ancient entity
and there actually is a nice way where
we can go about okay uh let's wait till
he daytime be what the heck
my chest were spent spazzing out so i
think yeah i
with the mysterious clock i get one
okay let's uh break you with you um back
up
yeah that one spider doesn't care if the
skeleton is uh burning
such a nice nice ride
kill you
you see the spider's chill sub spider
killing that spider bam 18 damage nice
all right now
let's try making him a a good distance
away
from our house
because if this doesn't work then
kind of screwed
all right i think
really good area to make it
bring it up yeah yeah that's good i like
wood planks
so you kind of make it like this
i don't need i think i think
i think like that oh yeah yeah yeah
because you can do then like
like this
yeah this is right all right
just to be safe
so i'm fairly sure this is going to work
and if it's not we're kind of screwed
so yeah there we go there's the ancient
entity he should be trapped he normally
has a super flinging power but i don't
think he can attack me
so let's just beat him down yeah
see we're safe normally he can throw you
up and also the wiki the wiki uh says
like
he is like uh 1800 health and he has 4
000.
so this might be a chance i don't know
would this go a lot faster
i don't want to risk jumping because i
feel like he might hit me if i jump
i was just taking so long it's like let
me numb some foods
how much time does this do this is three
ooh that's a lot of damage
okay we're almost one fourth of the way
there so uh
let me speed this up i don't know maybe
not
you can just get past all this if you
don't enjoy this
dice and you're a bossy man
i don't think i don't think he can feel
uh playing damage
yeah since yes he killing him um
will give me divine charge
and i need to make divine charts to get
to uh the
first dimension called graphite hills
why don't i get criticals there we go
uses
that definitely
okay
actually this armor was really good to
fight him with because uh he throws me
up in the air but i don't take call
names
so
eat him with the octopus i wonder if you
can repair this
plug in all these curriculums and aqua
10 has looting of
two so this one
just finished them off with the blood
gem death to you
there we go oh he gave us a five that's
not bad
he gives a statue why is it moving
ancient ancient ain't ancient entity
statue
now he also oh there oh wow oh awesome
i'm using that oh wow
he also has the chains the uncommon
chain to drop sand slash which is a
sword
who does good damage but only a hundred
uses man
and okay let's let's leave that there
and let's return to the house
back to home the episode's probably near
near being complete
as we have killed our first boss
and
so this is definitely good for extra
power
okay we got sand slash
who's not the strongest
not the strongest indeed man
oh dang it quite quite a quite a large
sword
i say if i place this in the ground he's
just
what the heck
that's funky does he move around no he
doesn't
we're gonna have to make a room of these
that's a fail get back here a little
stop facing that way
stop it okay i'm like
where'd he go
did he just like have to face that way i
don't think he can face another way
yeah okay okay a t can only face one way
okay we're gonna have to make a room
or we could like put it like that and i
don't
like that
this could be our wall for that for now
it'll be our wall
divine charts ooh we can almost make one
except oh my gosh define
we're gonna need looting three because
you need to make divine charge into uh
divine stones and then
i think divine stones into the divine
blocks
so you're gonna need 81 divine shards
for one divine block
dang
i'm gonna keep him here yeah
and then throw this stuff in here
all right guys well we even got a chic
axe
uh aquaton we killed an ancient entity
we showed the new armor and good stuff
all right guys i hope you enjoyed this
video my name is prestige you've got
this far leave a like comment rate or
subscribe and i'll see you all later
peace out